I'm about to show you the fastest and
lowest cost way that you can make a
spare key for your Chevy vehicle. Before
we get started, I'm gonna call the Chevy
dealership and find out how much they
want to rip me off for to make another
key like this. Here we go. I might be on
hold for a while. We'll come back to
this call later to show you just how
much money you can save. Check out how
easy this is. We're going to make two
new keys. I've labeled these both with a
purple and a blue tag just to keep them
separate. These are both a quality
aftermarket. Uh, this is the original
OEM key with the Chevy logo. We'll be
using this programming tool. As long as
you can use a smartphone, you should be
able to program a spare key for your
vehicle. It's important to know you must
have at least one working key that
allows you to start the engine and drive
the vehicle in order to use Tom's Key
Company do-it-yourself programming
solutions to make a second or a third
key. In today's video, we'll end up with
a total of three keys when we're done.
So, we we try to make it super easy.
We're going to start by scanning the QR
code. Opens up and you got to go get
your app. Okay, with the app downloaded,
I'm going to fire it up and we need to
come in. We're going to pair a new key.
So, first we got to find the OBD port
and insert the programming device into
it. The location of the OBD port can
vary by vehicle. Sometimes it's up here
under a panel. Often it's down near the
gas and brake pedal. Go ahead and plug
it in. Now, to make your life a little
bit easier so you can see what's
happening, I recommend picking up this
optional extension cable. Okay, we're
going to plug in the programmer. We see
it's got power. We need to get the
Bluetooth connection made. Okay, we're
going to press to scan.
We should see the matching serial number
and we can make a connection to the
device. Here we go. Our programmer is
now connected. And let's continue. I
want to point out today we're working on
a push button start vehicle, not a
turnkey ignition. So, this one has a
smart fob. We do have solutions for lots
of different types of keys and vehicles.
So, check our website. I also want to
point out there's great technical
support. If you want to have someone to
help you out if you run to issues, just
know that they're available Monday
through Friday, daytime hours. All
right, let's begin programming.
First, we need to enter the license
plate or scan the VIN. This is helping
us identify the proper year making
model. Okay, I've entered the license
plate. We're in check plate.
Should pull up a 2020 Silverado. It
didn't fully get it, so it's not
perfect. 2020. Here we go. Let's
continue. All right. What kind of key?
We have the smart key system. All right.
There's some important information. Uh
programming should take no more than 15
minutes. If it's running more than that,
you can call tech support right down
here. Don't navigate out of the app
during programming. And make sure you've
got all previously programmed keys
present. So, you've got to have one
working key. That's the one we've got
right here. This key, we have no other
working keys. So, just this one plus the
two that we're going to be programming.
Okay. Let's go ahead and start
programming. Please wait. You got to
have a solid internet connection on your
phone to do this. While this is counting
up, let me point out a couple important
things. The programming slot may be in
different spots, like in here, down
there in the cup holder, or around the
start button. The app or your owner's
manual will tell you. About 62%.
Be back in a moment. H looks like my
call to the car dealership is still on
hold. All right, we're just about there.
And here comes 100. All right, preparing
the dongle for programming. Saw my
Bluetooth light turn out. It's getting
ready. Bluetooth light turned back on.
Okay, leave the ignition off and turn
the hazard lights on. So, engine is not
running. My doors are shut.
Just turned on my hazard lights. They're
blinking. Okay, we'll go ahead and click
continue.
Configuring the system. Please wait.
Hazard lights stop blinking.
tells me a pin code 8624. Okay, jot that
pin code down in case you need to
manually enter it later. Configuring the
system. Please wait 45 seconds. The
ignition was dark. It just turned back.
It just lit back up. So, it's very
normal in programming. There may be some
different things that happen up on the
dashboard.
In fact, most Chevys will tell us it's
ready for the next remote when it's time
to program a new key or new remote. All
right. put the new keyless remote into
the programming slot area. It's located
either in the center console, view the
owner's manual. I'm going to take my
other two remotes. I'm going to set them
far away and put this this new one with
a blue tag right down here in the cup
holder. The key in the programming slot.
We can hit continue.
Okay,
dashboard just lit up. All sorts of
stuff going on up here. There's a
security light on. Verifying the PIN
code. Please wait. Give it a 10-minute
wait uh for the security system wait
timer. Let me point out a few important
things before you start. Make sure you
turn off the HVAC. Leave the radio off.
Be sure your headlights are off. Don't
have the light in the car on. You don't
want to drain your vehicle battery
during this programming process. Power
button has a green light and emergencies
continue to flash. This is really
important because if your vehicle
battery ever dies or the fob battery
dies, you're not going to be able to get
in unless you have the emergency
keyblade cut. And we have this awesome
key by photo technology. You simply add
the key by photo service to your order
and then you'll upload photos of your
existing key and we will cut your new
key so it arrives already fitting your
vehicle. Now you might ask, what if
something goes wrong? I've already
pointed out there's a phone number you
can call where where you'll get a real
person who will talk you through
problems that you run into while
programming. We also have lots of
answers to common questions. Visit
help.tomskey.com.
And if for whatever reason we can't get
the problem solved and your spare key
just won't work, send it all back to us.
You get a full refund. We're about
twothirds of the way through. Let's
check on that car dealership. See how
we're doing on hold.
This is Todd.
Hey Todd, I'm trying to find out what it
costs for another key fob for a 2020
Chevy Silverado.
This is just for the key in the
transmitter. You're at uh with tax
you're at 33130.
33130 with tax. Okay.
Mhm. and I can get you out to service
and they can let you know how much it is
for the programming.
It sounds good. Do you ever have any of
those keys people buy online? Do you
know if those work or not? I've seen
some for a lot less. But
yeah, I don't I don't know how well they
work. I know that I can't cut them on my
machine because they're a lot softer and
they they come on my machine and then it
it breaks our bits. So
Okay. Okay.
So I know I'm not able to cut them on
our machine. Um, but let me get you out
to service and they'll give you an idea
on programming. Hold on.
Awesome. Okay. Thank you.
Can't cut it on his machine. Whatever.
Did you hear that? 331 just for the key
fob and cutting. Back on hold. All
right. I'm 6 minutes into the phone call
just to find out how much they want to
charge. We learned it's $330 just for
the key fob. Now, we got to find out
about programming. All right, we're just
about done. I noticed the security light
has turned off. That's a good sign.
There we go. We finished our 10-minute
wait. Configuring the system. Please
wait.
Okay. Up here, we see ready for remote
number three. So, that means there's one
remote that's been lost somewhere in the
world. We can program up to the maximum
number the vehicle is allowed, which So,
I'm going to click the start button one
time.
And now I'm going to wait up here.
There. See that? It says ready for
remote number four. Okay. Continue.
Configuring system. Please wait. We're
getting some flashes. It says that
driver 3 on memory features. Do we have
additional new keys we want to program
the vehicle? Why yes, yes, we do. Put
the next keyless remote into the
programming area. Pull out the blue key.
Put in the key with the purple tag on
the dashboard.
I see it says it's ready for remote
number four. Okay, we'll go ahead and
hit continue.
Please wait. All right, we're going to
do the same thing.
Do
we have any additional keys? Okay, we're
going to say no. We've just finished
programming all the keys we need for
this vehicle. Configuring the system.
Please wait. The dashboard's turned on.
Click the start button once to turn the
ignition off. Yep, my dashboard's turned
on. Click once. Turn off.
Turned off down there. Press and hold
the vehicle start button for 15 seconds,
then click continue. So, let's do this.
1 2 3 4 12 13 14 15. Okay, let go. The
ready for remote message should be no
longer be displayed on the dash. If the
message has not gone away, press and
hold the start button for another 12 to
15 seconds. So, let's see. That ready
for remote is gone. What will happen if
the vehicle is not fully ended
programming? If it still said ready for
mode on the dash, this is a really
important point to follow because
otherwise what happens is you'll try to
start the engine and it's stuck in
programming mode. So, you don't want
that. If it does get stuck in
programming mode, there's a real simple
fix. I can link to another video or help
section will have info on it, but all
you have to do is disconnect the
battery, the vehicle battery, and it'll
help reset the computer. All right,
let's hit continue. Do not press the
brake pedal. Hold the start button for 6
to 10 seconds until the dash is fully
turned on. So, here we go.
1 2 3 4 5 6 7. There. See that? So, it
can fake you out. At first, a few lights
will turn on. You want to hold it on
till all the lights are on the
dashboard. Again, an important point to
make sure you fully exit programming
mode. I'm going to hit continue.
Configuring the system. Please wait.
Press the start button for two seconds
to turn the ignition off. Okay, here we
go. One, two.
Hit and continue.
Open and close the driver door once.
Opening the driver door. Closing the
driver door. Vehicle beeped at me.
Hit continue.
Configuring the system. Please wait for
about 30 seconds. Okay, be back in a
moment. All right, here we go. Hold the
brake pedal and push the start button to
start the engine.
Boom. The truck fired up. Look at that.
Engine's running. Okay, with the engine
running, let's hit continue. Click the
start button to turn the engine off. Hit
continue. Configuring the system. Please
wait.
Sooner or later, we'll get done with
this. Open and close the driver door
once. Here we go. Open the door. Close
the door.
Okay, let's hit continue.
Press the lock button and the unlock
button on the new remote. Listen for the
locks to click. Okay, I'm pulling out
the purple. I just pulled out the purple
lock.
Hit lock.
Heard them click. Hit unlock.
Okay, let's go ahead and hit continue.
If you heard the locks click, then click
continue. If the locks did not respond
the new remote, make sure it has no
battery. If the remote still doesn't
work, lock unlock the doors. You may
have an incorrect part number. Please
continue and complete program procedure
anyway to vehicle computer gets back to
normal mode. Okay, we heard the lock and
unlock click. So, let's hit continue.
Success. Configuring the system. Please
wait. Current number of program keys,
four. All right, this is good. Now, it
says four keys. Remember, we have our
one original key here. Program the blue
one, program the purple one, and then
when the vehicle was manufactured, there
was a fourth key. Well, it was really
the second key way back then. That's
lost somewhere in the world. So that's
why it says total number of four when I
only have three. Continue. Programming
successful. Please exit programming and
test your new keyless remote. Click
complete. System is restarting. Okay.
Program successfully completed. All
right. We can leave feedback. Before we
do that, we're going to unplug our
programming tool. All right. Let's make
sure our keys work. Unlock. Boom.
Unlocks the vehicle. Locked it. Let's do
the purple one now. Lock. Unlock. Look
at that. We'll check the original key.
Make sure it's still working as well.
Look at that. These keys are all locking
and unlocking the door. But there's
still something really important we want
to check. We want to be sure that each
of these is actually programmed to start
the engine. I'm going to turn off my
emergency flashers. I'm going to set the
three keys outside the vehicle far
enough away that the vehicle can't
start.
Okay. To find out if they're far enough
away, I'm going to push this. Try and
start the engine. Nothing's happening.
Look at that. What do we got? No remote
detected. So, that's good. That means we
can now bring each remote back in one at
a time.
So, I'm going to test all three of my
remotes. So, here's the original one.
Boom. Engine fires up. That's a good
thing. Tells me for this vehicle. That's
driver number two. Memory features.
Turn it off. Let's go get the next
remote. Take this one out of the
vehicle.
Okay, here's one of the new ones. Blue
one. Let's start the engine.
Boom. Look at that. Fired right up.
Tells us that's driver number three for
memory features. Okay, same procedure.
Turn off the engine. Get this out of the
vehicle.
We're back with the final one. Purple.
Let's try starting the engine. Press the
brake.
Excellent. Engine fires up. Well, we've
tested it. Let's leave some feedback.
Yes, everything is working great. Do we
need any help from the technical support
team? I don't think so.
Okay, there we go. We're done. Okay, I
also want to check I'm going to try
remote start. No, let me jump out. Lock
the vehicle.
Boom. Excellent. Fired up. Okay, now for
the tailgate.
Here we go. Beautiful.
Let me close it.
Let's make sure our passive entry works.
There we go. Excellent. Boom. Can you
believe how easy that was? I got two new
spare key fobs in about 10 minutes for
this truck. Now, you might ask yourself,
what if you run into a problem? You may
never have programmed a car key before.
Well, guess what? It's pretty easy, but
we know that issues can arise. So, we've
got support. You can call on the phone
or visit our website, help.tomskey.com,
to get answers to lots of questions. If
you've watched this far, will you help
me reach my goal of 10,000 subscribers
by year end? All you have to do is click
that subscribe button down below. We
want you to have new keys with the help
of Tom's Key Company. I'm still on hold
with the Chevy dealership. Let's find
out what they're going to rip me off for
and how long it's going to take. I'm
trying to find out what it costs to
program a new key fob. The parts guys
transferred me over to you.
Uh, yeah. Programming on a key fob. Is
it going to run you $180?
180 bucks. Okay.
331 plus 180. Yep. You're at 511.
511. Okay. And how long should I plan to
be there for for it? Um, I plan an hour
or two.
An hour or two? Okay,
sounds good.
Got to cut the key and then once they're
done with it, we can go start
programming it.
Okay, cool. Do you know if there any
place I mean that's really expensive,
right? Like 500 bucks for a key. Do you
know if there any other ways to get get
them cheaper?
Um, they
may or may not work and we don't know
until we try to program it. So, we would
charge you 180 whether it took or not.
Got it. Okay. cuz we got to go through
and do the process and I got to pay my
check the first time and we don't know
until it comes back and works or comes
back and doesn't work.
Can you believe that? $511 to make a
spare key fob for this Chevy Silverado
and they said it's going to take an hour
or two sitting in their waiting room.
Well, they do it. They weren't sure if
something online would work. Well, guess
what? At Tom's Key Company, we'll send
you everything you need to make the
spare key. will cut it beforehand with
our key by photo key cutting service and
you'll save a bucket of money and it's
only going to take you 15 minutes. The
choice is really simple. Come to
tomskey.com, place order today, and skip
the ripoff time and expense from the car
dealership.